eliza is with us in orlando florida hi
liza
welcome to the dave ramsey arthur the
ramsay show what's up
hi thank you for taking my call and i
appreciate what all you guys do i've
been starting to listen now since we've
had to stay home
so it's been a little education here but
i still have a couple of questions
and um my house has paid off
and i have a friend who told me why are
you paying the insurance
i mean when have you had something
catastrophic happened
since you bought the home well once when
um
hurricane irma came and i was going to
put the roof on myself but irma helped
me along so the insurance paid for it
so she says you got a full roof on now
what else can happen the fire station's
about two
two blocks from you um or either lower
the replacement value
and i'm just a little bit scared about
not having insurance on the house
because this is my only asset you know
that i have that
big-time money so i think your friend's
kind of dumb
right and he has money to back up if he
had any problem with the house i
i'm not that long i've got the money to
write a check and rebuild my house but i
have homeowners insurance
okay so i should just continue that
because i don't even know if i can
not have insurance on the house um
should i lower the replacement value or
should i leave it the way it is
you know if you're going to pay for
insurance pay for insurance that
replaces the house if it burns
okay well the fire station's two blocks
i know
but you still have something will still
burn i mean it can still
i mean i don't you the chance you're
having a total loss is
not there probably depending on what
happens
but um i mean i've been to orlando i was
there last week
there you guys have thunderstorms like
we have in tennessee
yes so who's to say you don't get struck
by lightning i don't know that's true
yeah because we're the capital for light
or lightning strikes yeah
yeah i but i wouldn't think i would have
been able to do it because i have an
equity line
on the house no they're not going to let
you i thought you said you had it paid
off
well the house has paid equity line it's
a off company it's with my bank with my
checking
i know but it's they've got your house
is not paid off they have a lien on your
house
yeah oh so and i've been just letting
that linger there because i just thought
it's like
like an open credit card type of thing
my husband's passed away so
now i'm dealing things on my own he's
probably rolling on his brave listening
to my conversation now
oh yeah no listen you're doing good
because you're asking questions and
you're learning that's always
good let's leave the insurance in place
and let's call the bank and cancel the
equity line
okay i don't because i don't have
anything hardly on it's probably about
500
or something yeah but the value of it is
like 30. so
yeah that's the the the pre it's an
accident looking for a place to happen
is what it is yeah
let's get rid of it absolutely yeah i
there are times that you can self-insure
through some things that you want to um
but not a house though right not a house
i i just
you know but i mean you know like i had
a a three thousand dollar jeep
yeah that was at the lake house right it
was just a lake house jeep yep
and um i did not carry collision on it
yeah
because they wanted like 500
for collision on a 3000 rg but i'm like
i'll just take the you know i'll take
the risk it's a 3 000 jeep i can
if i if the thing just explodes tomorrow
into a thousand pieces because
you know whatever i hit a wall with it i
don't know then then
i'll just get another one it's not
because it's not a big deal but
stu you know my nicer cars i still carry
coverage on
now because i've looked at it i'm going
okay i've got this vehicle that's worth
this
yeah uh i can afford to buy one of those
a month
right right even though it's expensive
but i mean i'm in a financial condition
to do that
right but i look at the value that i'm
covering versus what it costs me to
cover it
and i'll let them take the risk for that
ah it's just a value proposition for me
and so but you know technically
they're making money on me and and
technically it would cost you more money
if you didn't have it insured
i mean you have to go drop you know the
money when technically if you pay the
insurance you come out cheaper if
something was to happen well certainly
if something happens but that's when
they don't come out
right and on average you know they're
going to come out absolutely
that's the deal yeah but uh but i still
carry coverage on the cars
the nicer cars yeah and on other things
uh
and of course i carry liability on
everything lots and lots of liability
it's the best
buy in the insurance world and dave is
saying he covers he
he carries full coverage on the nicer
cars
yeah make sure america hears that yeah
but i don't you know but but you know if
i've got a
a farm truck or something i don't i
don't put a bunch of insurance on it you
know it's not what we're doing it's
it's a that's an easy enough thing to
replace and you have full coverage on
your lake house even though it's not
it's not as big as your
house but it's you have full coverage on
your lake house absolutely yeah
people understand that and they're all
paid for and i could
write a check and build one of those in
30 seconds if something happened to one
of them but i'm gonna
go ahead and let the uh let the
homeowner sit in place it's just pretty
simple